welcome to the MBA Mother's Day game
halftime report to celebrate the MBA
have us the MBA mothers during the
halftime commentary yes my name is Jay
mondegreen mother of draymond Green Lin
love get her loves mom God mom you know
what I like about your son he seems like
such a good boy such a sweetheart
he used to help me clean up and take it
out the trash he was helping me wash the
dishes and without even asking cause his
grandparents every Sunday that's
wonderful because I cannot get very much
to call me even you need to stream on
call your mother okay she's a lovely
lady okay what are you doing no but let
me not do that to my son on air today
Maya is a real sweetheart and he tries
his hardest he lights up the whole room
he takes care of his friends he pays for
the entire family Netflix and that is
one thing that should not be taken for
granted and not he doesn't have to
doesn't he does not have to cuz he's a
good boy good boy he's a good boy good
boy fun thing about draymond is he like
came out the same size as me he slid out
like a clone so he just messed me up
um okay so now the highlights of the
game so what were some of your favorite
parts of the game the cabmen is it the
Tron a Megatron in the middle of the
thing they do like the dance cam and the
kiss cam what do you like better dancer
kiss a girl
stop make a shovel about that they
should and you know what a little
segment of pups acts one more highlight
one two three what do you be ready
yelling oh my god they love the baby
races mm-hm I like sometimes when the
coaches get upset because they get a
little mad you know in our age range so
I just oh you liked it it's cute oh it's
um
okay yeah I like it now it's time for
the Southwest Airlines high-flying jump
so the slam dunk of the gang was by your
son Kevin Love not only is he a little
cutie patootie
that's not Wendy Williams that he has a
new girlfriend that is wonderful
hmm girls okay hold on so let's go ahead
and bring up the clip bow at the top of
the key
okay no I know what's controversial like
get it I get it I know modeling is a job
job okay so that seems as though that we
are out of time and we just want to say
thank you to the NBA oh you know and
make sure y'all call ya'll mothers call
your mom thank you girl I cannot face
these girls why do we do what do we do I
think oh they keep this one we're
supposed to rub a barrel okay
I don't think big here let me just tell
you if she even thinks about getting
president
[Music]